in other news national gas pipelines are
the latest flash point between Russia
and Western Europe amid tensions over
the war in Ukraine two pipelines started
leaking yesterday after a parent
underwater explosions European Union
officials suspect sabotage Charlie
dagada is in Ukraine where Russia may be
about to claim four Eastern provinces as
its own territory Charlie good morning
good morning to you Nate President Putin
is widely expected to formally announce
the annexation of those four territories
on Friday that makes this a fight on
Russian soil as far as he's concerned
wanting to use all means necessary at
his disposal to defend it
even with some of the worst of the
fighting raging along the Russian
occupied territories forced ballots cast
at gunpoint the head of russian-backed
donuts described a colossal Victory
saying it wouldn't be true to say we
didn't expect such a result neither did
anyone else no this farce in the
occupied territories cannot even be
called an imitation of a referendum said
Ukrainian president zielinski in last
night's address
the Ukrainian military released this
video said to show special forces over
running Russian positions in the donbass
region if President Putin annexes
territories here and elsewhere as
expected this week he can claim that
Russia itself is now under attack
justifying the deployment of conscripts
and even he hinted a nuclear response
the first of around 300 000 reluctant
reservists are being trained and are
expected to be pushed up to the front
lines long before they're ready let
alone willing to fight Russian men
trying to escape the draft have fled to
the border with Georgia line so long
they can now be seen from space
when you go to fight in a stupid War to
kill your brother says this man it is a
war about nothing a war President Putin
may not just be losing in Ukraine but in
Russia too
A Renewed nuclear threat comes from the
deputy chairman of Russia's Security
Council Dimitri Medvedev saying I want
to remind you the deaf who hear only
themselves Russia has the right to
nuclear weapons if necessary Gail
all right Charlie jacket of reporting
from Ukraine thank you Charlie